ات مراسله الجزيره بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
نصب حواجز واغلق طرقا رئيسيه في غلاف غزه
واعلنها مناطق عسكريه مغلقه معنا من غلاف
غزه مراسلتنا نجوان سمري نجوان اين تتركز
هذه
المناطق المغلقه في الغلاف وما الذي
يترجمه هذا التحرك الجديد للجيش
الاسرائيلي وقواته
هناك اسمحي لي بدايه مريم اشير الى ان
صافرات انذار تدوي حاليا في منطقه الغلاف
الشرقي في غلاف غزه اي في بلده عين هشلو
شاا ونريمان هذار تدوي الان في هذه
المناطق في اي شرق قطاع غزه في هذه
البلدات الحدوديه وحتى الان لم يتم
التبليغ عن سقوط قذائف او
اي صاف او شضايا لهذه القذائف يبدو انها
صافرات الانذار التي تدوي للمره الاولى
منذ اربعه ايام في هذه ال المناطق عمليا
مره اخرى
اي تعود المقاومه الفلسطينيه وتطلق
الصواريخ باتجاه بلدات الغلاف تحديدا هذه
ال البلدات التي طيله الوقت هناك نقاش في
الاسابيع الاخيره الماضيه بشان عوده
السكان اليها بعد ان قر وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يف جلنت قبل فتره عود او البدء
بخطه لاعاده عدد من البلدات التي تقع على
بعد اربعه الى سبعه كيلومترات عن الحدود
مع قطاع غزه ولكن في كل مره يتم اطلاق
قذائف صاروخيه وصواريخ من منطقه غزه
باتجاه هذه البلدات يثار جدل جديد و يصر
السكان سكان هذه البلدات على عدم العوده
وهو بطبيعه الحال ما يثق
كاهل على مستوى الميزانيات بطبيعه الحال
لوزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه التي تمول بقاء
هؤلاء السكان في فنادق وشقق سكنيه
فندقيه منذ بدايه هذه الحرب ونحن الان
يعني اربعه اشهر بعد هذه الحرب والسكان
يرفضون العوده والقضائي الصاروخيه مستمره
بمعنى ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما زالت
تتمتع بهذه ال قدرات لاطلاق الصواريخ
وايضا لمواجهه قوات الاحتلال في داخل ارض
المعركه في داخل قطاع غزه ويبدو من الملاح
من الملاحظ منذ صباح هذا اليوم ان هناك
قصف مدفعي تجدد وا يعني بقوه صباح منذ
صباح هذا اليوم على المناطق الشماليه بعد
ان توقف لعده ايام لكن نسمع هذا القصف
طيله الوقت يستهدف مواقع بعينها في
المناطق الشماليه في منطقه بيت لاهيه وبيت
حانون وايضا في منطقه شرق جباليا يرافقه
اي او ترافقه اشتباكات بالرشاشات الثقيله
طيله الوقت ايضا هناك استنفار امني
واجراءات امنيه يعني لم نشهدها منذ بدايه
هذه الحرب في الشهر الاول بعد نشوب هذه
الحرب كانت هناك عده محاور طرق مغلقه في
منطقه غلاف غزه وكانت هناك حواجز للشرطه
وللجيش الاسرائيلي بعد تم ازالتها وهناك
تحركات للصحافه ل ما يعرف هنا بغرف
الاستنفار وهي قوه امنيه تعمل في هذه
البلدات لكن هذا اليوم فوجئنا بعوده هذه
الحواجز العسكريه واغلاق عدد كبير من
الشوارع ومفارق الطرق الرئيسيه وقيل لنا
بان هناك حاله استنفار خشيه ان يتم
استهداف هذه المناطق بصواريخ مضاده للدروع
من المناطق الشماليه تحديدا في قطاع غزه
وعلى ما يبدو هذا يتعلق بحدث يشارك فيه
عدد من الاسرائيليين يتعلق
بحدث
سنوي بالطبيعه وقبل ايام اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه سيعود ويسمح لتجمع 100 شخص
في المناطق الحدوديه ولكن يبدو بان هذا
السماح مرتبط ايضا بحاله استنفار واغلاق
شوارع وحراسه امنيه مشدده لمثل هذه
التجمعات في تلك المناطق بعد اربعه اشهر
من الحرب ولذلك ايضا يبدو بان هذا القصف
المدفعي يستهدف اي تحرك ربما في داخل
المناطق الشماليه في قطاع غزه خشيه ان يتم
استهداف الاسرائيليين في هذه ال المناطق
من جهه اخرى الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث طيله
الوقت عن ان المعارك الضاريه ما زالت تدور
غرب مدينه خان يونس والاعين تتوجه في هذه
ال المرحله باتجاه رفح وهناك انتظار من
قبل القياده العسكريه اللي قرار سياسي
فيما اذا بالفعل س يتوجه الجيش الاسرائيلي
ويبدا ايضا مناوره بريه في منطقه في
المناطق الجنوبيه في منطقه رفح هو اعلن
بانه وضع خطه لذلك لكن هذا الامر يحتاج
الى قرار سياسي وسط خلافات تحديدا مع
الجانب المصري لانها المنطقه الحدوديه
بطبيعه الحال بين فلسطين ومصر شكرا جزيلا
لك نجوان سمري من غلاف غزه